[Music]
an indian couple is suing their only son
for over half a million dollars good oh
for not giving them grandchildren
half a million dollars what's what what
are they are they saying that they put
in half a million dollars in investing
into him just to get a grandson i mean
because they didn't get it
i agree you're gonna see her you're
gonna see tycho because they give you a
kitty's just like i just want my kid to
have a kid those are you with kids how
do you feel about this
i don't know like i got one kid so i
only have one chance i guess
you know how much you can assume for her
and i would never i would never fathom
like suing my kid for making a life
decision that he wants to make on his
own so if he if your son grew up and
said i don't want to ever have kids it
wouldn't affect you at all i mean i feel
i feel bad because i'd like to have like
future generations of my name continue
but i don't think i'd go to the extent
up soon my kid
yeah like my dad would be like
oh you sure you don't want to have more
kids do you want to have more kids
because i told him i didn't tell him
we're trying yet but we're going to try
this here but he was like you sure don't
have more kids it'd be nice to have wear
more grandkids i'm a [ __ ] you
only had one
you put pressure on me if you wanted to
have more grandparents only got one
chance i'm like if you wanted more kids
you should have had more kids instead of
[ __ ] putting it on me and then he's
like yeah did you see yourself when you
were a kid yeah that's a lot of pressure
you wouldn't mind if taika was like grew
up and didn't want kids yeah that's up
to him well he's going to be
um a gay in cell
i mean
he's going to be a gay
ancestor gonna be a gay incest boy you
need to elaborate i still don't know
where this is that's it that's all we're
gonna talk about that's your plans for
him you're gonna keep him on track
because he wants to get married to his
cousin that's what he identifies with
yeah so
i'm missing some pieces of this equation
boy cousin he wants to marry him so
that's why that's his future husband
yeah when you ask him who do you want to
marry he says my cousins okay there's
two dudes gotcha so that's what he wants
at what point will you be like
you by the way you can't do that it's
it's funny though because when you are a
kid you and you imagine i gotta spend my
whole life with someone it is the people
you have fun with most yeah yeah yeah
yeah think about what you're gonna do
like
i'm not gonna do it with a girl right
now and they'll get married and they're
practically just roommates yeah it's all
good my best friend is my cousin
am i it's true
if you were asked that yeah so this
family
they um they raised him educated him
only child by the way and they they
spent a lot of money to put him through
pilot school all this stuff this dude's
a stud and um and then when they married
him off i mean this is a different
culture entirely but yeah they don't
think that uh
that the kid is supposed to not have a
kid that's crazy in india too or is it
here indian oh
that's like for them it's like what do
you mean you're not gonna have a kid
that's weird
yeah that's like that's like a human
like necessity you have to have a kid
but then i feel like times are changing
though like in the developed world the
birth rate has gone down significantly
especially since kovid because
everyone's like fearful of like what do
i want to raise a kid into the global
warming and a pandemic and like job
instability kind of like thing and the
developed world the birth rate is going
up because they need some more
survivability of their of your blood so
maybe like what we're finding is like
more educated folks are are more fearful
of raising kids they should be
absolutely yeah i just want more
vacations bro and i just know that when
you got an infant around that's just not
happening you're locked down for 18
years yeah
when when was it when you realized oh we
could go on vacations together now and i
don't have to like
worry too much about like i don't know
like when you have a kid right you're
just like okay
there's like the first few years where
you're just like crying all the time
you're like man i can't even enjoy the
[ __ ] beach right now dude and then
later it goes like i think we could
travel
i think probably like when vincent was
like 12. but it wasn't actually until
just this year when he turned 18 where
i'm like i'm free really
yeah
so when he had his birthday party you
were also celebrating
and we celebrated edc and i'm like i'm
dancing out and i'm like i'm a free man
now
and he's like hey dad
was there any actual like overnight
change between him being 17 and 18 that
was like a thing that you were like oh
when you're 18 this will happen did
anything like
anything new occur like where i think
it's just more of a psychological change
okay
so you weren't like now you got to move
out no
is he uh gonna commute to school or he's
gonna go or whatever so he graduated
high school last spring okay and then he
he actually he didn't want to go the
four-year route like his friends did and
he took a a course up in
socal to learn how to fabricate with
carbon fiber oh hell yeah that's nice
he just started working for spacex a
couple weeks ago oh no way making
rockets yeah
but now for him
that's super dude so probably you must
be so proud
but like as a parent now it's like it
went from a perspective of like i would
hang up my son all the time we go work
out because i work from home we go out
for lunch go for dinner go hang out and
stuff like that and now i only see him
between the hours of 12 and two in the
afternoon because his work shift is from
3 p.m until 2 a.m oh that's got a
graveyard that's an interesting work
shift that's so funny so then now he's
the he's like the nine well not nine to
five but he's got that like gap of like
work where he's like disappeared comes
over dad give me a
beer it's like i tell my friends like i
got a roommate now that's cool sick that
you could just be like hey son can you
make me a splitter and a body kit for my
porsche
oh yeah when are you going to start i'm
going to start calling in those favors i
just started calling it all his
favorites
he like snuck home something maybe top
secret he snuck up some like scrap
carbon fiber from the present i was like
you might not want to say that
you snuck home like top secret
one of elon's rockets is missing a fin
as it's going up like what happened to
the fin i was like
did you see eric sports with the [ __ ]
hair
and she goes fast though dude it's
portions
of space sex on it
you say no i made this myself
meanwhile the rocket's just twirling
around in the [ __ ]
all of our calculations we're correct
who stole the fish
that's good all of our calculations are
correct and then the rockets like turns
and you see the fin missing and they're
just like
why it's the new kid again again
you got multiple chances of multiple
stolen fans that's so tiny
i feel like i like i really like kids
like playing with my friends kids and
like it's always awesome but then
my own
i don't know man it's it's just what do
you mean having your own i mean you've
had kids you know what i'm talking about
we're like the same age it's like come
on dude i see them and the [ __ ] they
gotta do i'm just like
oh dude i can't wait to have kids to
give away to people
i don't think that's what you strive for
like a wedding gift
congratulations i birthed you it's like
a it's like a takeaway thing in the
centerpiece of the table you're just a
child back in 18 years okay
watching like [ __ ] this uh show
versailles right and um out there like
there's no kids in the court so once a
baby like they pop out a baby like
that's it like [ __ ] the the princess
and the princes they just get sent away
and then other people take care of that
[ __ ] and then they come back
later on you don't even recognize your
own kids and [ __ ]
yeah that's how you want it that's the
jomalian way kinda
[Laughter]
yeah it doesn't sound too bad you know
yeah that's pretty interesting it is
right and then you have no emotional
connection to them
eventually you know when it comes to
their turn to reign that's why they can
easily kill you but i i'm i'm down with
the praying mantis [ __ ] you're not
really selling this very well you don't
want to build a vengeance with your kids
i think this only applies to joe i'm
like that's very joe's style it is yeah
it's pretty cool it's his own seed to
kill him and take the throne i give you
life weird now let me go enjoy the world
like his son stabs him in the back and
he's like ah that makes sense
so there's this classic book the homer's
odyssey right oh yeah odysseus so a
disuse was raised and he didn't know who
his father was or his mother because
they're raised by the court he ended up
falling in love with his mother
he didn't know it was his mom no i deal
with his mom he became a [ __ ]
you know yeah true story right joe is
going to create the next odysseus that's
kind of fire dude
i think that'll be pretty interesting to
see how it turns out
your kids are just science experiments i
think so
so here's another here's another little
factoid with this family that might make
you think differently they also paid for
the
son's wedding
bought a car for the son when he got
married so they did a lot of things that
uh did he ask
well i guess traditionally they are
supposed to do that too in that culture
so it's like i supposed to have kids
because of that so he because in i guess
i mean not in all indian culture but in
this particular case you are marrying
off your kid it's not like uh hey my kid
decided to get married it's like they
still do that stuff it's the investment
exactly
yeah i guess if it's like all
right like it was all clear and there's
an expectation so every single step
leading up to accumulation of 500 grand
i guess so yeah because what if he from
the jump said uh mom dad i don't want
any kids ever
like no pilots yeah no wedding yeah yeah
yeah but i wonder if this whole time he
was telling he was telling them like i
don't want kids they're like well what
if you know what if you get married you
know what about now he's like i still
don't want him yeah were you [ __ ] up
all he had to say was my balls don't
work
no they would they wouldn't yeah they
would go put them through a test yeah
like if they're gonna sue their kid they
would be like all right well we're gonna
go to a clinic right now and double
check that they would pay for like a
surprise come analyst to just burst in
the room
gotcha come with this cup like they do
for olympians with pp
[Laughter]
i'd love to see that business card here
the common analyst
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'll be taking this
traditional families that want to sue
their children
i wonder if your tastes come like a cop
does like this
you